well charlie i really appreciate you
loving that [ __ ]
this voicemail message sounds heartfelt
but
nothing about it is real i'll talk to
you in the morning
good night i love you and love you so
much good night girl
the man who spoke of love said he was 49
and lived in south africa
penny ward met him online on the dating
app
tinder he just seemed so so nice and we
just started chatting and
he was based in liverpool he'd been left
12 years
but at the moment he was in south africa
on a great farm that he just bought
but he was due back at the end of march
so he just said should we chat on water
if you want to like meet up when i come
home
the couple started speaking on the phone
they exchanged hundreds of messages a
day
but they never talked over video within
two months they spoke of love
and he asked for money he sent me an
email that said ollie's
machinery was in customs and he needed
twenty six thousand pound to get it out
which is
by that point i didn't wanna lose him so
i think i was just willing to say
anything to him to keep him
penny sent about 500 pounds but soon she
realized she was being scammed
as she tried to discover who this man
really was
she met a woman we're calling elizabeth
it turned out at the same time he was
using the same photos
same story but different name to scam
her to
we met on tinder and he was just so
lovely
and then before you know it you're sort
of addicted to being cared for
in a way that i hadn't been before
the man told elizabeth he loved her and
they planned she'd move to south africa
but then came the appeal for money for
his farm
i don't know i don't know what i'm going
to do
i don't know what i'm going to do 201
then they're going to release my
registration i
i shouldn't have wanted you elizabeth
sent 30
000 pounds it was all her savings
once he realized he didn't have any more
money his messages stopped
and you just feel like such an idiot the
story the photos all just lies
and afterwards everything seems too
obvious
i haven't even gone to the police i'm so
ashamed and what's the point
i'm never going to get my money back and
he's never going to get
caught i'm too ashamed to tell anyone i
know
i'm borderline now whether i lose my
house or not
tinder where the women met this scammer
told us we are saddened to hear of
anyone who has fallen victim to a
romance scam
when seeking a real connection we have a
zero
tolerance policy on this type of
behaviour and are constantly monitoring
our platform to detect
and remove any suspicious profiles we
encourage our members to look for the
blue tick
which indicates that the member's
profile image is genuine
and has been verified by tinder through
our photo verification
program but exclusive figures shown to
us by action fraud
show thousands of people are being duped
every year
reports of online romance fraud have
gone up
over the past 12 months and you'd expect
that because of the pandemic people
are at home isolated and more vulnerable
and victims in total lost a staggering
63
million pounds and remember those are
just the cases we know about
so how can you date safely i think the
let's get off here and go and chat
somewhere private is a real
red flag it seems perfectly natural in a
conversation so you have to recognize
that but
you know that the dating services have
messaging platforms which are monitored
which are
checked i think the other is things just
becoming
not real people who are instantly in
love with you can't keep away from you
penny and elizabeth both admit they were
lonely and vulnerable but they hope by
sharing their stories
others looking for love might avoid
fraud kathryn overtopsy sky news